Here are five copywriting books that you
should never read. Book number one,
Copywriting Secrets by Jim Edwards. It's
not a bad book, but it's like a really
ugly version of the Adweek Copywriting
Handbook by Joe Sugarman. Just go read
that book. Number two, The Self-Help
Guide for Copywriters. This is like
slogan writing. This has nothing to do
with copywriting. It's just catchy
slogans. The stuff in this book will not
sell a thing. The third one is
Copywriting. It's like an amplified
slogan version of the book I just showed
you. Definitely avoid both of these. The
fourth book is on my Kindle. It is the
Robert Collier Letter Book. Way
outdated. The language is hard to
understand. The pricing doesn't make any
sense, and it's way too dense. I would
skip that one. And lastly, some people
are going to hate me for this, but the
Boron Letters. More like the Boring
Letters. I love Gary Halbert, but there
was like two really useful things in
this book. Instead, go to his website,
print out his newsletter, and you'll get
a hundred times more value out of that.